coup de projecteur à présent sur une
application locale d'entr'aide entre
parents free bull a été créé par une
maman de saint-pierre-des-corps et prend
progressivement de l'ampleur elle met en
relation des parents prêts à s'entraider
pour garder leurs enfants ou échanger
des vêtements ou des jouets un service
où il n'est pas question d'argent mais
de bulles plus d'explications avec
tristan rickli
cet après midi elena parents de deux
enfants doit s'absenter pour aller chez
son coiffeur en quelques clics grâce à
cette application elle a pu faire garder
ses deux enfants par camille mère de
famille à saint-avertin ça fait 4 5 ans
n'ont même plus que ça presque six ans
qu'on utilise on connaît la maman les
enfants déjà été gardés par l on a déjà
gardé les enfants aussi et donc voilà on
aurait nouvelle expérience qui s'est
très très bien facile ça dépanne quand
on trouve personne on trouve pas de baby
sitter
c'est un échange en garde ont fait
garder
l'application est une plateforme
d'entrée d'entre eux famille elle
lançait l'année dernière par deux
parents tourangeau elle permet de faire
du baby-sitting collaboratif ou encore
de prêter vendre ou acheter du matériel
de puériculture
toutes ces actions permettent de gagner
des bulles la monnaie d échange de
l'application ou gagnent des bulles en
rendant service et s'est vue l'on peut
les réutiliser c'est une application
pour les parents faits par les parents
en fait c'est collaboratif c'est
solidaire on côtoie plein de parents au
quotidien autour de chez soi et l'idée
c'est comment justement au fait pour
oser l'entr'aide et balafré bull permet
de
soulever ces barrières là et 2 l
entraide rencontré à des belles âmes tic
sont créés au sein de tribus indiennes
maman qu'est devenue la témoin de
mariage de notre maman fribourg lors
qu'est ce qu'on n'essaie pas avoir par
exemple la plateforme financée par les
dons on n'en est qu'à ses débuts mais
vise à se développer à ce jour elle
revendique 500 inscrits en touraine et
plus de 5000 partout en france son
objectif avait passé le cap des dix
mille utilisateurs avant la fin de
l'année